the jurgen experience so she tells her
story about getting sent home
and you know eventually getting the aclu
to represent her
and um you know becoming what she is
which is this kind of great
this great symbol and also voice for
free speech
and the students take it in and they say
look you know miss tinker
you were fighting the good fight right
you were fighting the war in vietnam
this milo yiannopoulos clown like this
ann
coulter jokester like this ben shapiro
hoaxer
they just hurt people why should we
allow them to speak
and she had a very i think important and
pointed response she said listen
at my middle school there were kids who
had
fathers and brothers and uncles they
were fighting and some of them dying
in southeast asia you don't think they
were
hurt by this snot-nosed kid
wearing this symbol saying that their
loved one
was risking their life for a lie like
you don't think that hurt them
like if that's what you think like
you're not thinking like of course it
hurt them
so once that becomes like your you know
your barometer your measure
of what's gonna be allowed is speech
forget mary beth tinker
you know um forget anything because
words do
hurt right that in part was the point
right that was the point of the symbol
right
again i'm not saying that mary beth
intended to hurt anybody because i can
assure you that she didn't
but what i'm saying is it effectively
hurt people
right because speech especially
challenging speech does
and the students like take they took
this in and they said look you know
free speech it's just about who has
power and who doesn't
you know and the people with power they
love to talk about free speech because
they've got power
and mary beth tinker is like hold on
wait a minute i was a 13 year old girl
speech was the only power i had
and that's really our point here right
is that you know
when you start to restrict it in
whatever way
formally and informally right even with
the best of intentions
it's people without power ultimately
they're going to suffer
you know it's people at the bottom
they're going to get hurt
right because they need speech more than
anybody else
before the 1960s students had no speech
rights that
that the courts or the constitution was
willing to recognize
so you know if a student said something
in school that the teacher didn't like
they could just send them home
you know and it's because of mary beth
tinker
and the other kids who protested that
now it's not like that
right and of course we can debate the
degree to which this should be allowed
and
should you be able to wear a confederate
flag on your t-shirt or you know an
anti-abortion symbol and
these are all important things to talk
about but even the reason we're talking
about them is because mary beth thinker
who was
13 who had no power other than her
speech stood
up for her speech even though yes it
hurt people
right because speech does that um
but at the end of the day you know
that's really the message that i want
our young people to get
right is that the real reason i think we
need to hold on to free speech
is we live in an unequal society like
all societies are
and we live in a society with all sorts
of unfairness
all sorts of injustice like all
societies have
all right and if you want to do anything
about that
you got to let everyone talk that's the
only way the only way to make
anything better to write anything wrong
to right any wrong
is to maintain our free speech
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only
on spotify watch back catalog jre videos
on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience